[Music]
you like venezuela
do you like venezuela
ever been there ever wanted to vacation
there
no
well get ready because if the
progressive dems have their way
socialism will be as alive and well here
in america as it is in venezuela a place
once sitting on more oil than any other
country in the world which after years
of government overspending and welfare
programs with open borders is now a
perfect example of how socialism can
ruin a nation
now the rise of socialism has never been
clearer right now in america there are
forces dug in
organized and well funded to do whatever
necessary to make socialism happen
you've seen the slow crawl yourself
in 2016 bernie sanders ran as a democrat
socialist we all went
no
but four years later we found ourselves
in a country inundated with da's and
prosecutors funded by the democrat
socialists of america the george soros
types who were more concerned with the
criminal than the victim
aoc made a name for herself with the
green new deal pushing hard for the
socialist agenda contained in the 3.5
trillion dollar human infrastructure
bill human added to emotionally tie you
in and hide the fact that not all the
money is going for roads and bridges
this 3.5 trillion dollar alleged
billback better bill when added to the
trillions already been spent on the
pandemic will literally put us at the
highest level of debt america has ever
reached and break our bank
no worries though joe biden says it will
cost zero
we talk about price tags
it is
zero
price tag on the debt
i wouldn't rely on joe biden's math for
anything but no worries joe biden says
there is nothing radical in this bill
there's nothing in any of these pieces
of legislation that's radical that is
unreasonable for the first time biden is
telling the truth it is not radical
because in his mind and in any socialist
mind these proposals are key elements of
the socialist gospel joe biden who ran
as a moderate is really a socialist
won't you strip away that trojan horse
he wrote in on
now the bill includes free community
college for illegal immigrants so in
addition to medication housing health
care and education in grades k-12
illegals will have a free two-year
college education
79 billion dollars for enhanced irs
enforcement to conduct more audits biden
argues it will close the tax cap for the
amount of uncollected revenue and raise
funds for the white house's sweeping
spending plan
12 billion dollars for government
electric cars now this should make
hunter biden and the chinese happy
because we've purchased lithium
batteries from china
and there's three billion dollars for
tree equity
your guess is as good as mine on that
one
25 million from bias training as if
political correctness and cancel culture
haven't taught us enough about what is
tolerated in this woke country
there's four billion dollars for
distance learning isn't that special the
schools have gotten billions money over
and over again for the purchase of
equipment and the improvement of classes
does someone in the biden crime family
have a contract with a computer company
and by the way has anyone seen hunter
then there's 2 billion to support a
civilian climate corps who will probably
have more police power than police
officers in your town villager city now
don't forget a little known socialist
from vermont bernie sanders would have
been the democratic candidate for
president in 2016
but for hillary clinton's corruption of
the democrat national committee and he
would have been in 2020 were it not for
james clyburn pushing joe biden
socialists have been winning elections
at the state and national level
defeating even long-term incumbents
since 2016.
now even obama's cradle-to-grave
fictional ad called the life of julia
suggests an
anti-capitalist socialist framework
a growing number of young adults in the
united states actually hold a negative
view of capitalism
two years ago 58 percent of young adults
has had a positive view of capitalism
today only 49 percent of young adults
have a positive view of capitalism
socialism is not only accepted socialism
once whispered about is now being
promoted from the highest levels of our
government
so
back to venezuela
you probably won't like it there for
those of you who need reminding
socialism doesn't work
the crushing poverty and violence in
venezuela is the latest example people
go through garbage bags full of rubbish
to take whatever they can and then try
to sell the empty bags
we don't need women giving birth in the
streets or dying because the hospitals
are overcrowded or non-existent
socialists want what you and i have we
work hard pay taxes and believe in
capitalism none of us is planning to
move to a socialist state and if you're
even thinking of socialism and you want
to visit venezuela ahead of time be
aware that the risk of mugging
carjacking kidnapping and torture is
commonplace
and that's my open let me know what you
think on my facebook and twitter hashtag
judge jeanine
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else